hello everyone my name is jamie campbell
bower and today
i'm here to apologize stranger things
star jamie campbell bauer apologizes for
his character vecna's behavior in season
four it will all be over soon
[Music]
[Music]
i know a lot of people are mad at me but
my apology isn't just for you
it's for the main victim of all of this
yeah you know exactly who jaime is
talking about and this is your official
warning stranger thinks season 4
spoilers in three two
one
[Music]
[Music]
joseph quinn who plays fan favorite
eddie munson dies a hero saving the town
of hawkins
i love you dad
[Music]
which would definitely explain jamie's
remorse
joseph yo look things got really
complicated okay
totally normal reaction joseph after all
beckness demon bats did kill you i i did
some things i regret you know but what
when i took your life so
so how does joseph handle jamie saying
sorry these are for you
i hope you can accept my apology and
if there's anything else i can do to
make it up to you
i love them
it's all good mate all right joseph a
guy who's down for an impressive floral
display but jamie he's not done
apologizing and i'm sorry to to everyone
again i i'll go home and i really will
think about what i've done and while our
beloved eddie is dead the love from fans
has never been more alive it's a
completely overwhelming feeling
it's so lovely case in point check out
what happened over the weekend at show
masters comic con in london i just
wanted to say
thank you from all of us we're really
grateful that you're sharing your time
those sweet words brought the actor to
tears thank you for signing our things
for spending time with us for faking our
summer
and
i think that we've already connected
with eddie for one reason or another
whether
we like his music taste or that he is
the outsider like you mentioned i think
all of us are part of eddie and in true
hero fashion he cracks a joke to lighten
the
very mood of you thank you
et spoke with joseph earlier this month
you could tell he's beyond grateful for
the massive fan support the devotion
that the fans have for the show and kind
of
um how they've found space in their
heart for a new character
um eddie is just so it's heartwarming
and um yeah
i don't know what to say about it it's
been they've been so gracious and
welcoming it's
lovely something else that's lovely emmy
nominations specifically 13 of them for
the cast and crew of stranger things
well it's incredibly gratifying at the
award show this fall they're nominated
for outstanding drama series as well as
several other categories honoring set
design makeup visual effects and more
chrissy
this is from
[Music]
you